One Direction
[Music]
we're approaching a very spooky season
the season of Halloween when goblins and
skeletons play are you going for as
anyone for Halloween uh probably not
yeah I might if I if I come up with
something really inspired I might yeah
but going where and I know parties we'll
get arrested never mind I forgot we were
Boomers
um yeah what is I remember when like
older kids would come to the house like
teenagers when they were on the cusp
yeah like they hit puberty and it was
like uh you should not be
trick-or-treating yes and they were like
punks about they were like I remember
sometimes they wouldn't even have
costumes and and my parents would be
like what are you and they're like I'm
just like a guy you know they're like
they're like kind of like simply like
that's so old but anyways my favorite
thing to do around Halloween time around
this time is to watch
any movies and so my lady friend and I
have been compiling a list of movies
that we're just gonna we're just gonna
watch in October we have like one every
night or something yeah one every night
that's a commitment so so far we have
auditioned The Exorcist well we have a
bunch the movie called audition uh which
Zack Creager who directed Barbarian by
the way speaking horror movies thank you
to everyone who saw it you made it
number one yeah so Zach who directed it
he has this list uh an audition is
number one on his list but his Saint
Maude is on his list which I hadn't
heard of uh so you got a list anyway so
maybe Barbarian will be on on somebody's
list so I'm very ambitious yeah but I
just saw last night and it's excellent
it's like an elite horror movie oh yeah
I think I'm really proud you were
fantastic thank you you're just scared
very well thank you you made me scared
oh and you knew I was right next to you
yeah sure well thanks for going I'm glad
you got I'm glad you saw it I'm glad all
of you saw it and I'm glad you're all
listening to the show life could be a
dream life could be a dream
your dealership
you are listening still to life is short
and I'm your host Justin Long your um
number one at the box office
your number one host the number one host
with the number one movie
um and with me is always is my number
one brother sorry Damian the number tied
for number one
um Christian and co-host Christian long
hello what a horror movie have you like
been saving that do you want to watch
around the Halloween time uh you know
I've never seen and I've been meaning to
for many years I don't know why I
haven't seen it yet uh Rosemary's Baby
never seen it I've always wanted to up
until a year a year or two ago I could
have I would have been able to say you
don't both have to not have seen
Rosemary's Baby but um I did I finally
saw it scary right it's really scary
it's really well done there's one called
Let the Right One In uh which is an I
think Nicholas or don't look I don't
know there's a Nicholas Rogue movie uh
with Donald Sutherland and Julie
Christie that's on our list that um
people are often think it's similar to
the original Invasion the Body Snatchers
with Donald Sutherland yes oh love that
movie Jeff Goldblum scary
um some really good ones and someone I
haven't seen so I'm excited to like do
this October of horror movies but you
know what else is a great horror movie
what's that Drag Me to Hell oh I'm glad
you said that uh yes that's another I
mean you can't fully agree with me
because you're in it it's hard it'll
sound braggy yeah but I can say
um with confidence that it's it's a top
tier well horror movie you also were in
it I was I got cut out yes I was it was
Sam raymie cut me out yes Sam um I one
of the many things I love about Sam Remy
the director uh evil tattoo is on our
list uh but one of my favorite things
about we really bonded over
um having brothers and working with our
brother and uh Sam works with his
brother Ted Ted in fact wrote Dragnet
hell and um I always we I think we both
you know connected on that level and so
he he put you in the movie you played um
my brother I got cut out understandably
not because my performance but because
it didn't um I think he just kind of
like wanted
to give me something to do and um and as
a result now I get like little residual
checks from it to this day that's right
even though I got cut out I didn't I
didn't know that that happened but yeah
but it does if you get cut out of a
movie you still get residuals yeah you
got a person you get a percentage of
whatever you made doing the movie and um
but you what you you worked a day on it
you worked one I did and I remember uh
yeah I got a lot of my stuff got cut too
because it was it just it was your plot
it was like you as a teacher yeah it's
like who cares and then I mean you're
great in the movie but so much of the
performance was like you being like are
you okay like the movie was trying to
calm her down yes it was the movie it
was her movie and and uh and the her
we're referring to is our wonderful
guest today Allison Lowman great actress
Allison Lowman other things she people
might also know her from great movies
like big fish and white oleander and
Matchstick Men is so good she's such a
great actress Allison Lowman my my dear
friend
um former colleague League hopefully
future colleague as well is she one of
your favorites no I wasn't gonna say it
I thought it was implied and how I was
speaking about her and I thought I'd
save it I think she is she is and uh I
know she's one of yours and after this
she'll probably be one of yours so let's
get into it my catch up with my old
friend uh who who was dragged to Hell
many years ago but is really A Slice of
Heaven here she is Alison Lowman life
could be a dream sweetheart
again
[Music]
hi look at you you look so great
it's been so long I know oh man well
wait okay where to begin where where to
begin we gotta begin at the beginning
okay
um by the way I have braces right now so
I might
it's like it's I'm gonna sound weird no
you know it just makes you look even
younger oh great well that's good that's
good what are the prices for you have
great teeth so it's not to straighten
them it's because I was getting
headaches and to Make Them Crooked yeah
no more character you want a new
character character yeah I wish
um no I have to have them for a year
um but what so it's for like I was
getting headaches so I went into the
dentist and he said that I'm grinding my
teeth at night oh and so I cracked a
tooth and I need to
um be in braces to like align my bike
again
that's why so for a year so what is it
like do do you feel younger do you feel
like a kid so I hate it because I feel
like when I'm talking I'm I'm smart like
I don't know my my S is did you have
braces or no I always wanted braces I
have like I don't even see I have some
like Christmas no you have perfect teeth
yeah well you don't need it uh when I
was a kid these they're kind of crooked
on the bottom and and you know when
you're a kid when you're that age it's
like the everything bothers you about
your appearance oh yeah anything yeah
um you I I just realized you have kids
who are approaching that age now are
they that old no my 11 year old oh my
God 11. Billy I know can you believe oh
my God
easy is it crazy dude because it's
because you are with them all the time
like it is bizarre because I feel like
we did Drag Me to Hell like a year ago
oh my God I bet because I remember you
saying at the end of that you saying um
I said what are you gonna do next
because people also were like it was
such it was such a big it was Sam's like
next movie after Spider-Man so and you
were the lead and and I I imagine you
were getting like a lot of I hate using
this word but buzz and heat and all that
crap you know all the good stuff and
yeah when you when you do a role like
that and I remember you saying you know
I think I'm just you're like I think is
that Mark you were with Mark and he was
such a nice guy and I was like I'm so
glad you're with a nice person and and
but you were like I think I'm just gonna
like because I said well what are you
gonna do next you know and I had all
these plans for myself and you said I
think I'm just gonna like uh just like
get a farm upstate New York and just
like chill out we we did you did yeah
yeah but I thought at the time like oh a
lot of actors say things like that like
I have these you know I maybe I
shouldn't say a lot I I've thought that
I've said that before in the past like I
just want to check out and like get a
place and like raise your family but you
actually you said it and you you really
did it oh that has been like I have
wanted ever since I can remember like
yes like I wanted to be a singer and but
I also when I was I mean 10 years old I
wanted to have a farm in Ireland it was
so weird like I would put like you know
teen Bop like people had posters of like
guys I had posters of farms in Ireland
that's really funny such a weirdo but um
no no I love well now I that's what I
mean I was just in Ireland and the Farms
there I can attest I now know are
beautiful like they're so green and and
just they're they're stunning they're
beautiful well what's crazy I haven't
even been I want to go I've never been
to Ireland oh you're gonna love it I
feel like I've been everywhere else but
I want to go there but when you were a
kid what was it about Ireland Allison so
I just saw pictures in magazines you
know and just like wanted to just be
like milking cows then
um and collecting eggs from chickens I
don't know
[Laughter]
so cute yeah and it's so it's such and
but you actually did it so you so how do
you say that did Mark have the same your
husband Mark when you turn into director
um because Mark makes like kind of like
high octane action movies and yes
definitely and he you know he was all
for me just like you know expressing
myself and like oh wow and also he's
from upstate New York so he was like you
know I know this perfect spot near
Cooperstown I don't know if you know
Cooperstown yeah I've been there yeah
it's so beautiful yeah it's so pretty
so we got 250 Acres
um yeah um this is like oh gosh right
now 2010 or yeah what year was it or
2009
um right after it dragged me to hell and
then uh and then we had Billy and then
we we also um were like traveling back
and forth right to LA because uh taking
meetings and Mark was doing some other
movies
um but uh yeah we had chickens we had
ghosts so one of our gifts from as as a
wedding gift was
um his aunt and uncle gave us two goats
I was like oh my God this is amazing
what are their names oh my gosh I don't
remember but I know disrespectful to
their memory I know I I know
um but I can't remember the chickens
names one was uh Michael Jackson
I shudder to ask this but why did you
call them Michael Jackson and the toilet
they do not remember honestly like maybe
they strutted like him because he kind
of moving yeah
that's how I love yeah
oh my gosh but it was so we ended up
moving though because the winters in
Upstate New York okay were I grew up in
Palm Springs whereas that's right 127
degrees in the summer and oh yeah it was
in the winter
120 25 degrees in the winter yeah yeah
no
um no it's like 70 degrees in the winter
it's just yeah it's beautiful I mean
it's beautiful exactly it's a desert but
um so we I was just not used to that and
it was like culture shock for me I loved
it but one day I it was in February and
I'd already experienced like three
months of snow and I walked outside and
it was just beautiful right it's just
covered in snow everything was white and
I got claustrophobic like I couldn't
breathe I'm like I can't I have to see
grass I can't do this any longer what am
I doing so we ended up moving what is
mar what is that conversation like when
you see the white the beautiful
blanketed white of your out your window
and then you say you have this Epiphany
and you say to how do you approach that
with Mark
oh I'm just like we have to leave
there's no way
yeah yeah yeah yeah and is he is he
understanding in a moment like that like
no he's panicking like oh my God I just
bought this farm this is what she said
she wanted yeah yeah yeah you know
um but and we both have that like
Vagabond Gypsy uh yes what is it I'm
sure you have that too yeah totally yes
Wanderlust yes like yeah you want to
keep moving on the good news is that I
don't want to move on from Mark you know
that's like yeah yeah yeah so there's
something that's the anchor right you
want to just keep picking up and like
like in a houseboat yeah and just
traveling we love it but you can't do
that really with kids because they like
I was gonna say that was complicated
yeah it does
um so we had to eventually settle down
but then we lived in Ojai for a couple
years too that's right yeah
are the kids
um what do they think of what you guys
do like are they um how aware are they
living they've been aware like recently
my son he's 11. um he's been more aware
of it uh but he's he's kind of just like
non-plussed about it like just yeah you
know it's nothing really and and I'm
always mom like yeah like even with like
uh because that's the only one that I
really let them see
um the horse movie it's it's a kid it's
for kids it's for kids
um but he'll just be like you know Mom
you know uh oh my gosh what did he say
like you know it he's more aware of like
wow you look so young
that's nice that's nice yeah yeah I know
I'm like crazy but he's not like but
he's like it must be strange to be so
matter of fact about seeing your mom on
the screen yeah it is it is a little bit
you know but I have to kind of like it
it's it's different because I want to I
want to be mom you know I don't want to
be like I don't know
um because the character is like talking
back to her dad and and just yes yeah
yeah you don't want there to be any
confusion yeah look I'm playing a
character here you know that's right um
well you talk back to your dad yeah
exactly oh seriously no he was like they
they will pick up on that my daughter's
nine and then it's like oh well Mom
complains you know to her dad it's funny
they don't separate yeah how how old are
you how long are you gonna wait to show
them Drag Me to Hell
so okay so I personally don't think
dragged me to Hell's like in the horror
category at all because it's so
interesting yeah yeah yeah I I know what
you mean to me it's just like more of a
comment it's like comedy horror I guess
I don't know yeah it's more like um I
know it's funny even though I just have
I have a horror movie out this weekend
and my mom is struggling with whether or
not just well she's saying she can't see
it now and and I I she's kind of an
anxious person and I said I think that's
I think that's smart I don't think I
don't think she should see because it's
a it's a real you know hardcore horror
and right and and she said well you know
I feel bad because I've seen your other
ones and like dry and and Drag Me to
Hell came up and I thought the same
thing Allison like that doesn't I don't
know that it's it's definitely not like
true horror it's definitely not it's
more cartoon it was like didn't Sam
reference Looney Tunes a lot yes when we
were making it it's like it's like a
live-action Looney Tunes uh-huh yeah
episode and then also just making it I
guess it's like with the maggots like
they're gummy worms like how can you
take that seriously
um but you know that but people don't
know that much yeah I don't know
because I think some people are really I
mean some people listening to this fans
of that movie might be like what are you
talking about that movie like scarred me
that was um yeah you know it's I don't
know but but I guess if you know how the
sausage is made it's um yes that's right
yeah exactly like some people are I've
never been scared of a button before I'm
like oh my gosh no it's just a movie
yeah how did that movie
um do you remember what do you remember
how it it came to you how you learned
about it okay this was weird and I don't
know if I'm remembering it correctly or
not but didn't we hang out at the
Chateau okay this is really crazy so he
came to me with dragged me to hell I'm
trying to remember he didn't have a
script for it he got on the phone and it
was like three hours long as Sam this is
right yeah and and just was describing
like every single scene
um oh really yeah like walking me
through what this character was gonna go
through and he was writing it with his
brother at the time
um that's right and his brother was like
the main writer at the you know yeah Ted
um and uh so that's how it started was
him
um I think this is what my brother wants
to do and it was a work in progress
and then you and I hung out at the
Chateau completely separate from like
knowing I you know yeah I'm trying I was
trying to remember how long before we we
shot this was I in my brain which is
take it for with a huge grain of salt it
was a couple of years earlier or was it
just months earlier was it years because
because we were going to do another
movie together remember that that's
right I don't remember what we were
gonna do oh like it was called Dodge yes
yeah it was cool I was so into it
because um first of all I was such a fan
of yours I I think we met briefly
through Rock through Sam yes who I meet
everyone through when you guys did you
were doing Matchstick Men right and um
and and so so I was just such a such an
admirer of yours and yeah we met about
Dodge was like a kind of a Bonnie and
Clyde knockoff yeah to uh small town
texts and Kids On The Run and I thought
it'd be so fun to do with you hopping on
the motorcycle oh my gosh we should
still do that one we should we should
why not
um I know I'm jumping all over the place
but so what what did um so Sam walks you
through it that's so interesting yeah so
then he walked me through it and then
okay so then we had met and then I was a
big fan of yours as well and I remember
calling Sam and I was gonna be like hey
I just met this guy Justin long
um he's a great actor and so he beat me
to it
yes he was like so okay
he's up and coming and he's done you
know and and he was going off and I'm
like oh my gosh and then he said your
name this is the craziest thing that I
was thinking Justin long he's like what
oh my God so that's so flattering I
that's funny that when I was up and
coming now I've just come you know I
just that's when I was coming that that
uh so flatter that's well I'm really
glad we did this I know um Sam's the
best what what was what are your
memories of him like how do you describe
him so I oh my gosh when I think of Sam
I I love Sam well he's alive but like I
loved him no
um I will always
but no he um okay so when I think of Sam
I just think of him because like most
directors I feel like when you're on set
it's just like okay uh hurry like this
is here's the size you haven't memorized
right and they're like kind of hyper and
like it and you kind of like feel the
anxiety of like what they're going
through because they've got a big job
right so they've got to put the whole
thing together and and they got to make
the time of doing a certain amount of
scenes right so I never felt that way
with Sam did you right not at all he had
an ease he had a real cheese yes yeah
I remember him describing like the
process of doing dragon how the
um and he compared it to because he had
just been doing the Spider-Man movies
where he said it was like conducting a
symphony yes we were talking about this
yeah and he said whereas this is like
sir he called everyone sir this is like
a this is like more of a chamber piece
it's like a string quartet you know and
and he could be more intimate and he I
think he even described it as like
playing in the sandbox so he he had this
energy of like a of a kid of like oh
we're gonna do how cool is the you know
I remember him when he the one of the I
think one of the prop people where they
were showing him like maggots like
potential maggot options yeah do you
remember that day where they were like
I'm sure they showed it to you and he's
like so very specific about yeah which
he should be um and he yeah he was just
so childlike like you said yeah and just
very curious like like totally he was so
open to whatever I was like he is listen
with like every part of his body you
know how would you compare that style uh
Sam style to someone another like
heavyweight like Ridley Scott who
directed Matchstick Men I mean there's
some similarities
um like Ridley it was the same way in
terms of like just letting well like
both of them trusted I think this is
like a Hallmark of a good actor or
director
um is like trusting that the doctor
knows what to do right and not like
telling the actor how to act kind of
thing yeah um that was a similarity and
then just I feel like Sam is just a
little bit more like just imaginative
like he really did need his A.D you know
to kind of like keep him on schedule and
he would you know in The Sound Stage I
think we were on Warner Brothers lot
right
um for a little while I think so so
um and then no he would just take me
okay you walk in the door you take five
steps and then oh you see the lamia you
know and it was just like every little
detail was you know yeah he was so
specific he was so he's such a good
communicator but but that she needed to
be for a lot of that stuff because
whenever I see that movie I'm really
struck by the sound design which is
something I normally don't notice in
movies and how you it's such a brilliant
performance
I just had to run in when all the crazy
[ __ ] was over and be like are you okay
and I wanted to like get in there with
you oh no literally this is not about me
no like I have to say when you're when
I'm dying right on the train tracks and
you're like reaching out that is like
brilliant you're you're okay you were
doing off camera for me you were
supposed to you were always so I loved
working with you um I know people know
this but but I it's worth like pointing
out and reminding people that you're
reacting mostly to just somebody off
camera usually Sam right wouldn't he be
the one saying yeah and now there's a
bang I remember that he'd get really
like but he it made me laugh and I'd
watch you do it because you have to be
so committed and he's like and it's
Sam's little sweet voice not little boys
but like sweet boy being like and and
now and now you hear a crash you know
right yes life could be a dream
sweetheart
Drew Barrymore might be descended from
Hollywood royalty but her life has been
anything but Royal even the rich is a
podcast from wondery that tells the
jaw-dropping stories about the
tumultuous lives of the world's celebs
from the greatest family dynasties to
pop culture superstars in their latest
series Drew Barrymore rewriting the
story host Brooke and Arisha tell you
all about how Drew went from Child
stardom and E.T to a rom-com darling
born to a Hollywood Dynasty Drew's Big
Break happened at the early age of six
but childhood Fame led to some
difficulties in her life but despite the
hand she was dealt Drew never lost sight
of her second act she's one of the most
resilient people I've ever had the
pleasure of knowing small parts and B
movies led to leaning roles in major box
office hits critical Acclaim and most
recently her very own daytime talk show
which is great by the way and I got to
do it a couple weeks ago we had so much
fun catching up Drew Barrymore proves
that with enough heart and guts you can
always find your way back to the top
listen to even the rich on Apple podcast
Amazon music or wherever you get your
podcast you can listen ad free by
joining wondery plus Snapple podcast or
the wondery app remember the days before
streaming services you know when you
would come home from high school and it
was only you'd listen to Jewel it was
only a few hours until that TV show that
everyone was watching was going to come
on Dawson's Creek or Beverly Hills 90210
your friends were on their way over for
the watch party and the smell of popcorn
filled the room well in 1999 that show
was Buffy the Vampire Slayer in the new
podcast from wondering The re-watcher
Buffy the Vampire Slayer we're taking it
back to 1999. get out your knee-high
boots I didn't have those put your
chokers on I didn't have that and paste
that poster of Angel AKA David Boreanaz
decided to have that definitely didn't
have that on the wall it is time to
enter The Buffy verse if you've ever
listened to the True Crime podcast
morbid that you already know your hosts
join morbid co-host Ash and Elena as
they slay their way through Buffy's
Drama Action and romance Episode by
episode listen to The rewatcher Buffy
the Vampire Slayer on Amazon music Apple
podcast or wherever you're listening
right now you can also listen early on
Amazon music or early and AD free by
subscribing to oneary plus and apple
podcast or the wondering app
hello hello
too many things to talk about uh but
you're in some of my favorite movies
um I I love Matchstick men's so much
because I I I could watch Sam Rockwell
read the phone book and but he's I know
so Dynamic and I love that relationship
between the three of you with Nick
Nicholas Cage what what are your
memories of that what was it like
working with Sam and uh oh my gosh Sam
Rockwell and Nick Cage that that was it
was so much fun and like it was honestly
we just like played the entire time and
laughed like I've never laughed harder
besides with you okay good thank you
um and like just yeah it was just like
joking all the time and is Nicholas Cage
jokey is he kind of like he's joking I
learned a lot about acting through him
through both of them but like with I
remember doing scenes with with Nick and
just like we'd be working on the scene
that we were filming right and then we
would have to do like a major scene in a
matter of like an hour or two and he had
these long monologues and I would say
you know Nick are you ready you know for
this big scene coming up and he's like
what scene
and I'm like oh my God because see I
have to I have to memorize that I can't
like oh yeah me too wing it you know
yeah and he and he was like I don't know
let me give me the sides I'm like okay
here oh my God here you know and and he
was looking at it and he's slipping
through he's like I don't even know what
scene this is I've never seen this and
I'm like wait is he panic
it's not true because this scene has
been there the whole time you know and
um so he would like get to the scene and
that was like his shtick was just like
um oh that's funny pretending so he's
pretending like kind of
um in denial or or just what do you
think do you think he actually hadn't do
you think that helped him the panic and
now I'm wondering what his motivation
okay so when it finally came time
because I was very curious like wow I
cannot wait I see yeah what is it like I
Ridley's thought is gonna yell at him or
I don't know what could happen you know
whatever happens if he's good or if he's
bad it's gonna be entertaining for you
yes so I was like wow I want to see this
go down you know
um yeah and so this is gonna pan out
right and um and I knew like Ridley
would not be allowed to yell at him
because it's in a cage you know so I was
just curious but so
um he basically would uh
find his lines as it went like this yeah
it was very and even in the scene he'd
be like and I uh you know it's so
interesting I don't know how he was
gonna say it and then online would come
and it would be the right line
yeah yeah
wow well well it serves a part like that
too it's funny I know that performance
so well because I whenever it's on TV I
watch it that's one of those movies
where like I see it on TV and I I keep
so I know it so well so it it makes
sense that that was his I I don't know
if it was a process I don't know if it
was deliberate but um yeah that's so
interesting because he's supposed to be
like uh for the next word and it
actually is how people talk like it is
if you're you know it's interesting but
do you think it was deliberate on his
part do you think Nick Cage like I
wonder if he kind of knew that that was
going to help the performance or or if
he truly was like oh [ __ ] what are we
doing I if I had to go on my Instinct I
would say that he knew
that he uh I don't know like he that's
what I would think yeah like he knew he
used it yeah for sure
and I do remember thinking just like you
thought
um I don't know like is this going to be
the one performance in his whole life
that's not good you know right right am
I part of the first bad Nicholas Cage
performance uh and I imagine Sam was
like the opposite and Sam was very
prepared absolutely the opposite I think
I remember Sam even in the beginning
because we had rehearsals for it like
looking at me like I'm worried for this
girl like is she good like he's very
professional and yeah on it with even
rehearsal I don't know my recollection
of him just being his friend was always
that he he he spoke he loved you he was
he was always like you got him you gotta
come hang man you gotta meet Alice yeah
exactly like him
I like doing Sam listening oh yeah yeah
you look like it
I'm so insane through this selfish
reason I'm glad that Sam has gotten
really like famous and and his
recognition is um because now I can do
my my impression publicly yeah
Sam Rockwell how do I know you know
because for so long even up until like
Matchstick Men kind of like people were
like oh actors knew him actors knew him
that's right yeah right he wasn't like a
common household name or yeah yeah but
now we're so happy to see when I talk
with people like you said like people
know who he is and they also finally
because it's just like he's just so
talented
um they see that they're like oh my God
he's one of my favorite actors you know
yeah yeah yeah I love that movie and and
um also what about what about white
oleaner that was your big would you say
that was your big that was the first
like okay so I had done independent
films and commercials but you know how
you don't know like I don't know why I
was so I was 21 but I don't know why I
didn't think this thought but I never
thought of like any of the movies being
theatrically released I just thought I
would do independent films
and like nothing go unnoticed for the
rest of my career
so I don't it was just I just never
thought of myself as like being being on
like the Silver Screen right like never
being
um on the big screen right oh yeah so
um I remember doing ADR for White
Oleander and Peter kuzninski the
director was like so you do know that
everybody's gonna see this movie and I
was like yeah you know like my parents
and friends and family that's what I'm
thinking and he's like out of the video
store yeah the video store just like you
know like
um just a small you know not Festival
yes yeah the Palm Springs
yeah like I didn't even think that I
just thought it was going to be like my
my the independent films I'd done before
which really didn't get seen
um and he was like no no it's gonna be
like everybody's gonna see this movie
and well because Michelle also like
right Michelle like her yeah Michelle
Pfeiffer Robin right right Zellweger
it's like a cast of like really
prominent yes actresses yes
um and so of course yeah yeah and and
and so when I think back on like me
wanting to be an actor it actually never
was because I you know I feel like a lot
of actors like want to be famous you
know I really did not want to be known
at all yeah that knowing you that that
makes sense
um I can attest to that you that is not
at all in your yeah which is why when
you were on the cusp of like being
really known you were like you know what
I'm gonna like do something more
important yes which I love and um I just
feel more comfortable because the truth
is like and that's actually why I do
like why I like teaching acting classes
is because I
um don't I feel like anybody could be an
actor because I was that way I never was
really trained and
um I know Sam Rockwell was trained and
and you were not really I I didn't
really train I did like a class here and
there but like Sam loves the process of
training and is very driven that way but
what was your like what was the thing I
don't think I know this like how how did
you
um get into it how did you fall in love
with it so I um was very shy
um and still am but I know how to kind
of like work past it now yeah because
I'm 42. but
um but like along the way it was just it
was one of the things that scared me the
most was was talking in front of people
um so and then
um I was able to be somebody else
talking right like yeah that makes
effort so I wanted to be a singer that
was my thing all right and then
okay so then how did that segue into
acting um well I couldn't really get a
job as a singer so I was like I'm going
to make money doing anything what can I
do in LA because I I got accepted to NYU
I was going to do the Tish School of the
Arts program uh the musical theater one
um but I deferred because it was a lot
of money even with a scholarship it was
just too much so I went to LA I thought
I'm gonna go to La make some money and
then go back to school but um so anyway
I kind of like got into doing
commercials because I needed to make
money
and then when I started like and I
wasn't into acting at all
um I did like a Barbie commercial and
then I did denting and you know just I I
didn't care about acting then
um but since what you have to do in the
dentine community I had to swap gum
gum with a guy in the car we were like
teenagers
chewing gum
shy and it was I it was awful it was
like my worst nightmare I'm like wait I
have to like it was just awful it'd be
that'd be awful for any person yeah
oh so who was the guy shy too was he
kind of like he I he was better about it
than me but
um
so it's like good news and bad news the
good news is you got the part yeah
seriously uh uh and then they were like
you're gonna make this much and I'm like
okay I'll do it no
um I'll swap whatever
um
but so okay so then
um after doing a few commercials I
started getting to getting Independent
films and that's when I got into acting
because I was like I want to make this
character good you know like I wanna I
wanna and so I started watching movies
and getting into movies and
um what kind of singing did you do
before that I mean what was yours this
is crazy but when I was younger all I
wanted to do was be on Broadway
I wanted to do musicals on Broadway
so I did you know I did Annie and all
the the community theater musicals I
could do
um and uh but I thought if I moved to LA
like people are going to want to see me
sing like belt out Broadway tunes right
and I was just so naive like nobody
wants to see that you know
um so it was just you know I never
really like so you kind of stumbled into
acting through that I didn't know that
you were it was saying is it do you
still have a love of singing is it
something you still do so I will sing
for my kids and that's about it oh
that's so sweet life could be
do do do do do do do
hello hello again
[Music]
we have a lightning round Alice if
you'll indulge yeah what is that ER okay
just a quick I shouldn't call it a
lightning round like a short question oh
yeah sure
um what is your favorite emoji your
go-to your texting oh my gosh I just
thought of this the other day it's so
crazy
emoji that I'm like
the most right is the one that's
laughing not crying but it's got like
the squinty like like it's squinty eyes
squinty to the sides and it's like yeah
because I feel like that one can
Encompass a lot of like uh I'm being
kind of like kind of funny but not but I
don't know yeah but like oh but maybe
that wasn't a great joke but uh and
that's take it or leave it yes that's
more of my personality so I I feel like
I I tend to use that one the most yeah
it's funny I use similar ones I use the
uh the um
because it's like if I say something
funny or or I think it's funny and I'm
not confident about it um who was your
first celebrity crush
oh my gosh um yeah I know these are hard
hitting Michael J fox because oh hey me
too really
yeah I loved him family his eyes Family
Ties was like the first TV show that I
got into and I just I loved him and
still do I mean yeah me too yeah yeah he
is that did you ever meet him did you
ever get to meet him no um but my
husband or Mark you know Mark
um he uh
how to ice skate or something yeah no
kidding oh for um because oh cause he's
a hockey yeah Mark was a hockey player
in New York City in the big in the
outside rink in the Park oh my God I
can't remember the name of it
um yeah how did he come to do that oh
because Michael J fox was needed to
learn to ice skate or play hockey or
something like that for a movie yeah
yeah I'm not crazy and then and then
it's oh it was life with Mikey maybe was
it life with Mikey was it was it in the
90s it was in the 90s yeah yeah it was
like it might be wild um uh okay what is
a favorite ice cream flavor what is your
favorite go-to ice cream flavor oh my
God Justin that is like you just opened
a can of worms because like ice cream's
my favorite thing oh good and I can
never choose but I know okay so Jenny's
you know Jenny's oh yeah Chinese is
great that's my favorite like I like
everything in Jenny's I love
um but right in this moment yeah if you
went into a Jenny's store I don't even
know I went into a Jenny store
okay uh lately Boston cream pie but
maybe but maybe the or the um not Oreo
the mint the mints yeah the mint is so
good that Boston cream pie is delicious
yeah
yeah
um I think you can get it on um I just
discovered this thing uh gold belly do
you know gold belly yes no where you all
tend to have it delivered yeah do you
have it delivered oh but if you were to
go to the Chinese store do you get it in
a cup or a like a a waffle cone I get it
in a waffle cone but usually I come in
and honestly just grab seven pints like
I'm just like I want all of these and I
will take it home and eat it while I'm
watching a movie or something
um what is your what is your favorite
holiday how probably Christmas
it's probably a lot more fun with the
kids it is because they just get so
excited and then I just like I like like
you know a fire and it's cold outside
and but not too cold yeah not too cold
and I also feel like people are gen like
generally just like happier and nicer
and I don't know it's like yeah
yeah which we need now there's some
cheer in the air yeah it'd be funny if
you were like man I really miss the
winters the snow Christmasy the white
Mark's listening to this he's like what
no
okay all right moving again uh what what
is an acclaimed movie that um you're
embarrassed to admit you haven't seen
like people maybe shame you for well
gosh just about everything because I
haven't even seen anything
like anything but the Godfather oh I've
seen the okay oh oh oh um the one with
Sylvester Stallone
um rocky rocky yeah I've not seen Rocky
any of them oh okay okay but you know oh
Mark Mark would probably shoot me I've
never seen any Star Wars it's just not
my deal what yeah I think I've tried
that's not my deal yeah isn't Mark Mark
must love Star Wars
he Star Wars is not his thing either
really oh I'm surprised but he loves
like Rocky of course
um well not of course but um he's happy
Italian I can see that oh yeah and he
also loves The Godfather yeah what well
wow sorry so you think you'll ever watch
Star Wars you you might watch it for the
first time with your kids than with
Billy probably maybe I'm so curious what
you think of it um
okay uh what is a uh what is it uh do
you drink coffee or tea and if so how do
you take coffee for sure
um okay and so um
I like usually actually Mark makes my
coffee every morning I like it how he
does it
um it's just
like real cream that we get it's
actually raw cream from a local Farm
um and then
um just like an Americano or a latte
yeah and then pouring the cream in with
a little bit of coconut sugar and that's
it huh oh cool oh that sounds good um if
you could learn uh what is your favorite
cereal
I don't eat cereal
um okay good that's easy then yeah
granola I guess granola uh if you if you
had to choose a different first name
Allison's a perfectly nice name pretty
name but what would you choose
okay so my one of my favorite movies of
all time is true romance with Christian
Slater and Patricia Arquette Alabama
besides Alabama and I just I don't know
why I was gonna name my daughter that I
named her Georgia instead but
um it's cute but Alabama to me like I
just think it's the cutest thing
it is
I love boys names for girls what do you
call it Georgia do you call her George
George Georgie yeah or George yeah both
yeah that is really cute Alabama Loman
um
it does I like it it flows Alabama
um if you had a sandwich named after you
the Allison Lowman sandwich what would
be on it what would that be comprised of
oh boy
sandwich I make egg salad sandwiches
okay it's just I love it
um and I put do you have a special way
to make it lots of onion
um I don't put dill pickle in it
um nope you lost lost me but
um I guess I'm playing but sometimes
like I'll do tuna fish and I'll put
lemon zest and that is really good
um
okay and on what type of bread so let's
let's stick with the egg salad
sourdough and that's it okay egg salad
no pickles and extra onions on sourdough
yup because you could add bacon and that
would be really really good that's
interesting uh and and yolks you you
keep the yolks in some people do
definitely keep the yolks yeah do you
double up on the yolks there's a there's
a recipe on the uh Famous Deli I'm
blinking on a Zan Zaba or Zanzibar oh
right yeah they do
double yolks I did not know that but I
would do that I'm gonna try it okay okay
um what uh what is your favorite Tom
Hanks movie
um
I love Sleepless in Seattle
um my brother's favorite I love love
that one
um but gosh he I mean he's so oh well
and Forrest Gump is really good yeah
that's right what is yours
um I think well I think it's now big I
just re-watched big I haven't seen it
since I was little so yeah it goes so
good it is no yes no no I totally forgot
that and actually I showed it to my son
he's 11. and I thought oh this is gonna
be dated I'm not gonna like it he like
thought it was the greatest movie ever
ah yes yes and then he showed it to his
friend and he was like this is the best
movie ever it's called big and and he
showed it to his friend and his friend
was like this is terrible like because
you know the production quality of it is
like not as good the picture
um
it's like fuzzy right the the oh oh I
guess our is that a sharp yes it's not
it because they're used to I don't know
it well
I've noticed there they might be used to
more like quicker Cuts that's what it is
yeah yeah you know because he didn't
like
well that it struck me watching Big how
patient a lot of it is and it's not slow
it's so engaging but it's um it's all
done in a lot of like they do a lot of
Masters you know a Penny Marshall is
just she's I but it makes me really like
appreciate um those movies now because
they don't I and makes me feel old
because I I continuously I like
constantly find myself saying well they
don't make them like they used to it's
true uh they don't they don't because
kids don't have as much patience as we
did yeah yeah um yeah I didn't think I
had any patience I know compared to now
though it's really wild yeah
um but uh yeah you have to like wait the
the more drawn out it is right the more
emotionally attached you get to the end
and then it's a it's more such a great
it's such a great payoff like
heartbreaking and he's so good and
everybody's everyone's so good Elizabeth
Perkins is great um who is the guy uh oh
he passed away recently um really good
actor who has played the father in um
his best friend home alone his best
friend no no they're kind of like the
bad guy kind of like the the the one who
states oh I know the best friends those
kids are great yeah oh man anyway uh so
good big you gotta watch it um do you
prefer the toilet roll over or under
way
your pan your pan TP honestly I feel
like I'm just like in a hurry it's
terrible but
however as long as it's there I
literally like I hope my four-year-old
does not come in so I better make this
quick oh my God that's right and and
Allison finally we just have one more
thing because I know we're out of time
um if you would mind wouldn't mind
finishing the sentence Allison Lowman
finish the sentence life is short so so
live it
yes I love that no no I love that it's
no it's poignant and so uh efficient and
it's there's a it's
profoundly the most generic one but no
Alice and I [ __ ] love that I swear
I'm not just saying that I I love that
life is short so live it yes [ __ ] yes I
mean it applies to all of it well I'm so
glad you seem to be living it so well
and I I couldn't be happier oh my gosh
it's so good to talk to you yeah you too
you're one of my favorites I've ever
worked with i i and you are like the
only actor I ever keep in touch with so
oh yeah
there's no literally people are like so
What actors do you know you know I'm
like none except Justin long he's the
only one I want to know I'm just kidding
oh he's sweet you're the best I I miss
you I'm so glad we got to do this oh my
gosh this is amazing and one of these
days very soon hopefully I'm gonna try
to coax you out of um out of retirement
because because I would love to work
with you let's do it with Sam okay let's
do Sam okay all right with either Sam
Ray me or Rockwell
yeah all right all right I love you so
much I love you too Justin
okay thanks pal bye bye
[Music]
so that that just happened just happened
she's got she's got like the slightest
and she always she's got the braces I
know I know it's so cute she's even
cuter she's like she looks so young
still I know when she said at 42. she
always looked young she was like yeah
wasn't she one of those actresses who's
like in her mid-20s playing like 14 year
olds yes yeah like me yeah yeah and she
was like the female always yeah she was
always so young looking but she still
looks so young and I realized when
someone has break when an adult has
braces
it freezes them in a certain in my mind
in like a certain age bracket remember
when Tom Cruise had braces remember that
Tom Cruise he had braces like um as an
adult yeah yeah he got braces in the
maybe 90s or I remember there's like a
period of time where he had like clear
of course he had clear ones and then
yeah I used to think the metal like kids
who had metal braces he was like it was
cool like it was like tough yeah yeah
they were like bullies yeah not that I
aspired to be a bully no no no but like
tough like popular yeah you know both
have to think kids boys with metal
braces were tough and popular
um I know I don't know why
um but Allison Lohman yeah man what a
what a very cute still just
don't say this a lot too it's but a
sweet person like a really it doesn't
make sense like just knowing her a
little bit now how how she was able to
play those Innocents those um yes she
played such an innocent and um but
that's why Matchstick Men is so good
she's so good because they use her
spoiler alert I know you don't want to
give away the no The Twist it's a great
twist it's a great it's a really good oh
man yeah but yeah she is she has such
like a kind spirit and also the fact
that she took a you know retired
essentially after that movie it really
shows you how like truly little she was
interested in being famous totally yes
and I know a lot of people say that a
lot of actors say well I'm not really
interested in the fame element of it I'm
just more about the work but there's
something obviously so seductive about
the The Perks of Being famous yeah
so for someone who is
uh on that level to just walk away from
it it really shows because you don't see
that a lot no no it's a real it shows
how little she actually cares about
being famous yeah and I believe that and
I I suppose I care I definitely care
more than she does because I I stayed in
and I care more about about doing that
that um but I always wondered you know
with Allison if there was a part of her
that missed the other stuff missed uh
acting and she really does seem
genuinely content you know with that
with not doing it and and I think that I
think only a person who's had a taste of
it and is wired the way she is and is a
so pure of heart the way she is I think
it requires those things and and and
like having a taste of it a little bit
to know otherwise you'd never know like
well what what would it be like to go to
the Cannes Film Festival gussied up and
gussied yeah should we read a letter yes
let's do it oh look behind me oh Andrew
of Sleepless in Seattle oh and True
Romance yeah Jenny's ice cream yes Queen
yes scream Queen yeah yes scream Queen
Jesus scream Queen
oh yep whoa okay let me clear my
throat for this one this is uh elani
from Karen Maxwell
k-a-r-i-n subject a letter and would you
rather from Karen not a Karen
hi Christian and Justin let me Begin by
let me begin my letter by saying I
started listening to your show early on
during the pandemic and it has stayed on
my regular weekly podcast rotation ever
since I enjoy listening to your
brotherly banter and the kindness and
respect you show your guests
speaking of kindness and respect I've
heard you question what it must be like
to have the name Karen these days I
wondered if she was going to get into it
uh I can't speak for all of us this is
Karen I can't speak for all of us but
these have been trying times to be my
friend I won't lie there have been
instances where I've heard people talk
about Karen's in public and it's really
bummed me out and made me want to change
it having the name Karen has made me
even more confrontational averse I bet
oh yeah it's interesting because people
are ready they have an expectation about
you oh yeah so you're already it
actually might be good good I know being
aware of other people and respecting
other people in a non-caron way is
probably good for Karen's and non-carins
um back to Karen my Karen Karen Karen my
name has been a source of frustration
since I was very young I'm 40 and
growing up in the late 80s and early 90s
in a sea of Ashley's Lindsay's and
Heathers oh my God yeah I'm so true so
true my name was usually reserved for my
friend's moms yeah we're the same age
yeah yeah there were a lot Ashley's and
Heathers apparently Karen was the only
name my parents could agree on when I
was born and my mom said she would be
fine with naming me this if uh it was
spelled with an i instead of an e She
always told me it would build character
to speak up for myself and correct
people when they spelled it wrong that's
interesting yeah that's such great uh
like force yeah on your parents aware of
yeah that's so smart huh I'm sure if
either of my parents knew my name would
turn into a noun for older white and
often racist ladies flying off the
handle about first world problems they
would have come up with something very
different that's so true that's funny
that's really funny the first name I
heard who know I mean you never know
what's gonna happen to a name yeah or if
some somebody with that name is going to
turn out to be like a a famous [ __ ]
you know like Adolf yeah that's what I
was thinking of um the first time I
heard Karen used negatively was in a
Dane Cook stand-up set you can easily
find it on YouTube at that time I
thought it was funny and only slightly
offensive several years later Karen
memes started popping up followed by
videos of Karen's acting like complete
lunatics these videos sealed the Fate
from my name for the foreseeable future
now my kids hear the phrase don't be a
Karen thrown around school left and
right I think they're slightly
embarrassed by my name although mostly
they just feel bad for me when they hear
someone use it in a negative context I
received my fair share of sympathetic
looks when I tell people my name and it
only makes me want to change it even
more man I bet and I wonder how Dane
Cook was had his finger on the pulse of
Karen being I wonder how he used it he
was so popular oh my God so when I was
in college yeah
um I have had back to Karen I've had
multiple conversations with my husband
about changing it to my childhood
nickname Carrie Lou my middle name is
Louise that's that's cool Carrie Lou I I
I'm into the Carrie Lou Carrie Lou
sounds like Mary Lou yeah I like that
and it's kind of unique Carrie Lou it's
it's it I like it it's got a um maybe
um
like Mary Lou Harris yeah Carrie Lou
Carrie Lou Maris or like carry on Carrie
Lou it sounds very Southern okay it does
I like that Carrie Lou I like that
Carrie I say I know I second that that
your husband uh it sounds like his her
husband likes it so you're like Foghorn
like horn yeah where's that caraloo it
sounds very Southern but I'm native
nashvillian so it is on brand I'm still
workshopping the name change but in the
meantime I use my last name or my
husband's first name for all host stands
and food orders I'm thankful his name is
Casey huh
if you're thinking he is mistaken for a
female on paper you would be right Casey
Musgraves although I think she doesn't
Ian her she does and she's a female yeah
not to be labor my name was but my
maiden name is Shupe
s-h-u-p e pronounced Shoop so you can
imagine with the fifth and sixth grades
were like for me when the salt and
pepper hit Shoop was getting heavy air
time and it's funny when you're the same
age as someone you have like even if
you're from different parts of the
country I know like you have culturally
such similar experiences yeah and that
was that they played that oh my God it
was a frustrating few months I bet but
now I love that song uh my married last
name is much better and let's hope the
internet doesn't tarnish Maxwell
was that a joke because
I don't know if that's I don't know if
it made I think of uh our parents dog
Maxwell yeah me too Maxwell uh is a
scrappy little Street dog that my
parents love
um I think Maxwell silverhammer who
cares what I think this is Karen's
letter back to Karen in the meantime
I'll continue to try and be kind and
caring as much as humanly possible since
it's the way we should all be handling
ourselves to begin with well said my
husband has always jokingly suggested
this should be my personal catchphrase
you have to care out to care in oh yeah
that's good I never realized how much
Karen sounds like caring yeah it does
isn't it bizarre that that name is
associated with someone who is so the
opposite of wearing well they only cares
about themselves or they care about the
wrong things yeah um anywho
anywho I love that most letters that
sign off that way thanks for the laughs
every week kindly Karen or Carrie Lou
Maxwell uh
I'm gonna adopt Carrie Lou Maxwell
Carrie Lou Maxwell P.S you mean the name
not the person not the person no P.S
here's a very on the nose would you
rather great in 2022 would you rather
have the name this is a great question
would you rather have the name Karen or
dick wow no contest dick yeah
because Dick is um so it's a male well
yeah but why did that matter oh yeah I
don't see gender I um I forgot dick and
Karen Karen is just so popular now as a
specific thing whereas dick is people
might like immature people might chuckle
out your name once in a while which
would be totally fine with me like I I
wouldn't care at all that my name was
Dick he went and Karen in fact if
anything
I might kind of like it because it might
be fun to leave I would lean into it
yeah you'd have to especially with our
last name dick I do like what I would
lean into it in the way that our uncle
dick yeah hasn't yeah exactly the way
that Paul Rudd does in that movie Wonder
have you seen those outtakes from
wonderlust oh yeah yeah you can go and
get my dick
um diak long in 2022 would you yeah I
would too and um but I was gonna say to
Karen uh that she can also make it a
mission like a Karen on behalf of other
Karen's like good Karen's uh she can
make a mission to to rewrite that now
negative
moniker yeah restore it restore it to
its former glory
yeah Karen um but I like Harry Lou and
this was a great letter God what a good
yeah I'm gonna really she sounds like a
funny person and uh he's got a good head
on those shoulders Cameron Miss Maxwell
uh so thank you and thanks to to Casey
for um well if he listens if he doesn't
listen I don't know what are you
thanking him for I don't know listening
to the show what if he doesn't listen
yeah that's what I'm thinking man you
might not so forget it Casey
um but uh thank you so much to
my friend and and now the show's friend
uh just the delightful uh very talented
Allison Lowman yes she is wonderful
she's wonderful and Kristen's Crush
continues I'm updated yes oh and also if
anyone would like to write into the show
to complain about their given name or or
for any reason really our email address
is life is short at wondery.com
and uh thank you to everyone listening
all the Karens out there and Casey's and
whoever you may be yes and go check of
course Jerry O'Connell of course Jerry
um best friend of the show also go check
out Drag Me to Hell if you haven't seen
it and a barbarian oh whoa double horror
plug me plug and um check out uh
everything next week check out the show
next week please please Our Guest you'll
have to wait and see oh not patience
definitely this is like being slowly
dragged to hell not knowing thanks
everyone
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me Justin
long oh no yes it's October but it's
co-hosted by you the vet that dastardly
Christian long it's also uh produced by
you and it's produced by Megan B Monaco
and Katie the Al and Senior producer
Michelle Mish Lance the audio engineer
Sergio Enriquez I'm executive producer
Marshall Lewis for wondering
[Music]
twigs
to prompt the formerly known as twins
like in high school was she Twigs
I don't know like print I mean it's like
the artist artists formerly known as
friends
but he but you had to say that whole
thing I don't think he went in oh you
know I didn't know this is so stupid I
didn't know
I didn't know that's what FKA stood for
in the picket Twigs I did it no isn't
that that's sad it's not sad it's not
that common of an acronym FKA I thought
you were supposed to say
F just FKA twigs which is the most
annoying form of that name to me Fick is
kind of fun to say look at Twigs I don't
know if you're supposed to say Thicket
Twigs or FKA twigs or I think it's just
wigs actually but if she's the artist
formerly known as Twigs she's not the
artist she's just formerly known as
Twigs yeah then why would you call her
Twigs you can call her Twigs anymore she
was that's a former name that's true
Shia LaBeouf calls her Twigs because
he's familiar with her
he knew her when she was Twigs before
she was when she was like that was my
original question do you think she was
ever twigs
she would have to be for it to make
sense right
um yeah I would otherwise her name's a
lie formerly known as twigs
well maybe it's some kind of uh
existential thing like we were all part
of the earth at one point she was just
Twigs she was just formally oh like uh
sticks
yeah she was just like yeah it's kindly
like in the in the nature in the world
yeah they are so bad if you like our
show please give us a five star rating
and a review and be sure to tell your
friends the next episode will be out in
a week but you can listen to it right
now ad free by joining wondery Plus in
the wondery app you can follow this show
on Amazon music Apple podcast and the
one reapp or wherever you're listening
right now in the episode notes you'll
find some links and offers from our
sponsors please support them another way
you can show support for the show is by
filling out a survey at wondery.com
survey so thank you for supporting